as europe enters winter amid an energy
crisis gas stocks are 21 below normal
levels parliament debated how to limit
the impact of unprecedented price rises
improve energy security and support the
most vulnerable
meps debated the implications of the
so-called pandora papers a leak of more
than 11.9 million files disclosing how
the rich and powerful avoid paying taxes
on a massive scale
tensions and military presence have
grown in the arctic over recent years
meps called for peaceful development in
the region based on three principles
safeguarding the environment
sustainability
and international cooperation
meps called for better protection of
women and their children from partners
especially after separation since the
beginning of the pandemic emergency
calls for domestic abuse have risen by
60 percent
around 22 700 people die on eu roads
every year meps call for investment in
safer roads lower speed limits in
residential areas and zero tolerance
drink driving policies in order to reach
the goal of zero road deaths by 2050
[Music]
you